Oh, what up my baby?
Madonna, Rhianna, Ilana!
I'm the king of America!
Hello, Garol.
I'm nuts for nuts.
I'm not sure if I'm in
the right place.
You are.
Okay.
I was cyber bullied within
an inch of my life last night.
Eight thousand dollars!
Just now, a child in South
America died of starvation.
Would you like another?
You know what, I would.
Yeah.
I'm gonna lose a flip flop.
You're wearing a dog hoodie.
Is there a pocket on the back?
This is not Billy Joel's
go-to Dave 'N Busters. Okay?
I am a doo doo ninja.
What does that even mean?
Will you look at
that gorgeous tush?
Talking about my butt
?
Yeah.
Yes.
Yas queen. Yas queen.
Star of Ugly Betty,
Judith Light.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, I'm kissing Abbi.
Oh, come on. Deeper.
Mom, I can't. You're ...
The noises.
Lobster rolls!
Man, I feel like a smoothie.
Manuka honey!
So reasonably priced.
I'm a little baby.
Baby, you bird. I will not buy
a Sodastream full price, Bevers.
I will not do it.
Drop it!
I'm sorry I got you maced.
We look exactly alike.
That's what's so hot about it,
it's like hooking up
with yourself.
Bazinga.
Fist.
Uh huh!
Dude, that's the street.
Hope you like stevia.
This is amazing.
Yeah.
I make dolls out of human hair.
Who's thirsty?
I know you from your ass,
better than I know your face.
But we all know who's
the star of the show, here.
This dog is sexually
harassing me.
Oh my God!
Abbi! Abbi hold on tight.
So a horse dude
and a dude dude cannot -
What a bitch.
Aren't you a hot diggity dog
and a scallywag to boot.
I'm sorry! Trey,
I did not just fart.
Okay, that's a woman's fart.
Oh. Is it, Kirk?
I told you when we met
that I hate music.
How you doing?
This Haliburton fat
cat lunch is on me.
I have a girlfriend.
So do I, she's right here
with the ugly hat on.
Get in that box!
No, you have some explaining
to do.
Butt clenched,
I like 'em nervous.
Oh, what the-
You still have
your performance bib, right?
Maybe we really are witches.
Of course we are.
We're gigantic humongous witches
.